Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is. First up, a confession. This podcast is actually paid for by a consortium of the Knights Templar and Lizards from Outer Space. Our job is to change the mindset of you, our listeners, by overwhelming you with tendentious historical parallels, thereby softening you up for a global takeover led by George Soros and Elvis. Actually, Dominic Sandbrook, my co-conspirator with me here, that's not actually true, is it? That's nonsense.
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。就是这样。首先，坦白一件事。这个podcast实际上是由圣殿骑士团和外星蜥蜴人联合资助的。我们的工作是通过铺天盖地、带有倾向性的历史类比，来改变你们这些听众的心态，从而为乔治·索罗斯和猫王领导的全球接管铺平道路。说真的，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，我在这里的同谋，其实这不是真的，对吧？这纯属无稽之谈。
Well, some of it's true. The tendentious historical parallels, that's true enough. Yes, that is actually true. I mean, maybe if we encouraged a few influencers on social media to suggest that this is in fact the case how long before some people actually believed it to be true do you think well that's a good i mean the thought that we could influence anybody um it's frankly beyond the realm of the imagination but um yes so today we thought we would do conspiracy theories. And a great subject to me had an amazing response on Twitter when we put this out, which just shows the appetite that people have for believing that, you know, tiny groups of highly influential people like Tom and me control the world.
嗯，有些是真的。那些带有倾向性的历史类比，倒确实差不多是真的。是的，那确实是真的。我的意思是，也许如果我们鼓励社交媒体上的一些网红去暗示这实际上是真的，你觉得要过多久才会有人真的相信这是真的呢？嗯，这倒是个好问题。我的意思是，我们能影响任何人的这种想法……坦白说，这已经超出了想象的范畴。不过，嗯，是的，所以今天我们觉得我们可以聊聊阴谋论。这是一个很棒的主题，当我们把它发到推特上时，得到了惊人的反响，这恰恰说明了人们有一种强烈的倾向，愿意去相信诸如汤姆和我这样一小撮极具影响力的人正在控制着世界。
So obviously JFK, the Templars, the Freemasons, the Rosicrucians, the Protocols of the Elders of Zion, the Popish Plot, you know, was Barack Obama actually a Russian sleeper agent born in Kenya? I mean, the statistics, Tom, are amazing. So to kick off, a recent poll by NPR, the American National Public Radio, asked Americans if they believe that a group of Satan-worshipping elites who run a child sex ring are trying to control our politics and media so that's the allegation at the heart of q anon and 17 17 said it was true that they they thought these satan worshipping elites were trying to control the media and 37 said they didn't know so in other words you've got more than half who either believe it or are sort of
所以显而易见，肯尼迪遇刺、圣殿骑士、共济会、玫瑰十字会、《锡安长老会纪要》、天主教阴谋，你知道的，巴拉克·奥巴马实际上是出生在肯尼亚的俄罗斯潜伏特工吗？我的意思是，汤姆，这些统计数据太惊人了。所以作为开场，美国国家公共电台（NPR）最近的一项民意调查询问美国人：他们是否相信有一群崇拜撒旦的精英正掌控着一个儿童色情网络，并试图控制我们的政治和媒体——这就是QAnon核心的指控——其中17%的人表示这是真的，他们认为这些崇拜撒旦的精英正试图控制媒体；37%的人表示他们不知道。换句话说，超过一半的人要么相信，要么处于某种
ambivalent um that's extraordinary, isn't it? But not unprecedented. I think that's the interesting thing. Not unprecedented. And you can see the way that conspiracy theories take root at the moment with the rollout of vaccines. And obviously there are all kinds of conspiracy theories about vaccines. So there's the idea that COVID-19 vaccines will alter our DNA, that they're going to implant microchips into
矛盾的态度。嗯，这太不可思议了，不是吗？但并非前所未有。我认为这才是最有趣的地方。并非前所未有。你可以看到阴谋论在当前随着疫苗的推出是如何生根发芽的。显然，关于疫苗有各种各样的阴谋论。比如，新冠疫苗会改变我们的DNA，它们会在人们体内植入微芯片，
people, that volunteers in the trials died and it's being covered up, that Bill Gates is somehow involved, that vaccines for the Spanish flu were responsible for the 50 million deaths. And this has an actual knock-on effect because I think in France, I think over 50% of people are saying that they don't want to take the vaccine. So that's not good news at all. So I think, I mean, the key thing about this episode is not just to look at, you know, conspiracy theories in and of themselves, but to explore the way in which they hold a mirror up to the times and also the way that they have actually influenced the course of events and often the broad sweep sweep of history i think it's a very very fertile idea i mean dominic you um you you write mainly about um the modern period and you've particularly
临床试验中的志愿者死了却被掩盖了，比尔·盖茨在某种程度上参与其中，西班牙流感疫苗导致了5,000万人的死亡。这产生了实际的连锁反应，因为我认为在法国，超过50%的人表示他们不想接种疫苗。所以这绝对不是什么好消息。因此我认为，这期节目的关键不仅在于审视阴谋论本身，还在于探索它们如何为我们这个时代照一面镜子，以及它们实际上如何影响了事件的进程，乃至历史的大趋势。我认为这是一个非常非常富有成效的想法。我的意思是，多米尼克，你主要写现代史，而且你早期的研究领域特别是尼克松。关于尼克松，有趣的地方在于……尼克松，是的。我想关于尼克松有趣的地方在于，他因水门事件而倒台，而水门事件实际上——那是一个后来被证实是真的阴谋论，对吧？确实如此。关于水门事件，迷人之处在于它——嗯，就像所有这些事情一样，它实际上是一场无能的闹剧，而不是什么精英在控制一切。所以关于水门事件，对于那些不记得的人来说，尼克松的竞选团队、连任竞选团队试图窃听他们的对手——民主党人，但方式非常无能。他们闯入水门大楼，试图安放窃听器，结果事情败露了。有趣的是，
you know your early field of study was nixon yeah i guess what's interesting about nixon you know he's brought down by watergate Nixon. Yeah. I guess what's interesting about Nixon, you know, he's brought down by Watergate and Watergate actually, I mean, that's a conspiracy theory that turns out to be true, isn't it? It is. The fascinating thing about Watergate is that it's, well, it's like all these things. It's really a saga of incompetence rather than sort of an elite that's controlling everything. So in in Watergate for people who don't remember the Nixon campaign the re-election campaign they tried they bugged their um they bugged their opposition the Democrats uh but in a very incompetent way um they broke into the Watergate building and they tried to plant wiretaps and it all came out and and the interesting thing about
尼克松，是的。我想关于尼克松有趣的地方在于，他因水门事件而倒台，而水门事件实际上——那是一个后来被证实是真的阴谋论，对吧？确实如此。关于水门事件，迷人之处在于它——嗯，就像所有这些事情一样，它实际上是一场无能的闹剧，而不是什么精英在控制一切。所以关于水门事件，对于那些不记得的人来说，尼克松的竞选团队、连任竞选团队试图窃听他们的对手——民主党人，但方式非常无能。他们闯入水门大楼，试图安放窃听器，结果事情败露了。而有趣的是，
that Tom which bears out what you were saying earlier on, is that the reason they did it is because Nixon himself was a conspiracy theorist. So Nixon believed that there was a conspiracy out to get him. He had always believed it. He believed that the Kennedys, that people who'd gone to Harvard, that the big sort of northeastern intellectual political establishment were plotting against him, that they were bugging him. And he constantly said to his aides, we have to do to them what they're doing to us. So he basically orchestrates this conspiracy because he thinks he needs to tool up to fight the existing conspiracy against him, which, you know, didn't really exist. And he is operating against the the paranoid style in american politics so two i mean two massive conspiracy theories that are presumably floating around um while nixon is president who shot jfk is yeah is the whopper and i think already um by the time of nixon's presidency you know the years that immediately followed the moon landings, already people are starting to speculate that that is a fake as well. Yeah, I think the JFK one is the bigger one. So the moon landings is a mad one that I think gained traction slightly later.
汤姆，这印证了你刚才所说的话，他们之所以这样做，是因为尼克松本人就是一个阴谋论者。所以尼克松坚信有一个阴谋要搞垮他。他一直都是这么认为的。他坚信肯尼迪家族、哈佛大学毕业的人、东北部那些庞大的知识分子政治建制派在密谋反对他、在窃听他。他经常对他的助手们说：我们必须以其人之道还治其人之身。所以他基本上策划了这场阴谋，因为他认为自己需要武装起来，去对抗那个现实中并不真正存在的、针对他的既定阴谋。他在美国政治中根深蒂固的偏执风格的背景下运作。因此，嗯，有两个巨大的阴谋论在尼克松当政期间大概到处流传：谁枪杀了肯尼迪？这是一个惊天大谎。而且我认为，早在尼克松总统任期结束时，也就是登月之后的紧接着几年里，人们就已经开始猜测登月也是伪造的了。是的，我认为肯尼迪遇刺案影响更大。所以登月是一个疯狂的阴谋论，我认为它稍微晚一点才获得广泛传播。
The JFK one though, I mean, the JFK one is a classic one because it's that classic instance of people taking a seismic event that seems to come out of the blue and i mean one of the we'll talk about this no doubt but one of the perennial appeals of conspiracy theory is that it allows people to explain the the inexplicable so the president was shot apparently by a lone gunman but but people find that hard to handle they don't like the idea that of the random the contingent element in history. And so they try to fit it into these sort of existing, as you say, the paranoid style in America, which is, if you think about America, America was set up as a rebellion against an out-of-touch elite on the other side of the Atlantic. But also America is set up as a sort of Puritan shining city on a hill surrounded by corruption.
然而，肯尼迪遇刺案是一个经典的例子，因为它典型地展现了人们如何面对一个看似突如其来的震撼性事件——毫无疑问，我们将讨论这一点，阴谋论长盛不衰的吸引力之一在于，它让人们能够解释那些无法解释的事情。所以总统显然是被一个独行枪手枪杀的，但人们很难接受这一点，他们不喜欢历史中那种随机和偶然的因素。因此，正如你所说，他们试图将其纳入美国现有的那种偏执风格中。如果你想想美国，美国建国之初就是作为对大西洋彼岸那个脱离实际的精英阶层的反叛。但同时，美国也被塑造成了一座坐落在山巅、周围充满腐败的清教徒光辉之城。
So there's always this sense of sort of being embattled and sort of shadowy forces moving against the American Republic. And the people tried to fit the JFK assassination into that. They said, well, it must be the CIA or the mafia or the Cubans or whoever it might be. And they do the same with Watergate and the moon land moon landings as well so that's definitely an american tradition that kind of what richard hofstadter called the paranoid style well it's it's a very unfair question but i just wanted to ask you as someone who really knows his modern american history who do you think who shot jfk i mean was it just a random guy The answer is so blindingly obvious. It's obviously Lee Harvey Oswald.
因此，总有一种四面楚歌的感觉，仿佛有暗中的力量在针对美利坚共和国。人们试图将肯尼迪遇刺案塞进这种叙事中。他们说，这一定是中央情报局、黑手党、古巴人或别的什么人干的。他们在水门事件和登月事件上也做了同样的处理。所以这绝对是一个美国传统，也就是理查德·霍夫斯塔特所说的“偏执风格”。好吧，这是一个非常不公平的问题，但我只想问你，作为一个真正精通现代美国历史的人，你认为是谁枪杀了肯尼迪？我的意思是，那真的只是一个随机的家伙吗？答案显而易见。显然就是李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德。
And the key thing... But he wasn't brainwashed by the Russians or the mafia or... He wasn't, Tom. And I always think the giveaway, the single fact that the conspiracy theorists never address is the fact that if you employed Lee Harvey Oswald, even as your patsy, why would you not provide him with a getaway car?
关键是……但他也并非被俄国人或黑手党洗脑……他没有，汤姆。我一直觉得最明显的一点、也是阴谋论者从不提及的一个事实是：如果你雇用了李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德，哪怕只是作为你的替罪羊，你为什么不给他准备一辆逃跑用的车？
Why would you allow him to roam the streets after shooting a police... Because that's what they want. That's precisely the fiendish cunning of it. He shoots a policeman, the fiendish cunning, I mean, come on. You know, he was brainwashed by the KGB. I mean, you know, anyway. Yes. But you're right, aren't you, that of course it provides a kind by the KGB I mean you know anyway yes but you're right aren't you that of course it provides a kind of reassurance I mean that's that's the unspoken truth about conspiracy theory is that it enables people to think that even though they may be kind of
为什么在枪杀了一名警察之后，你还要让他四处游荡……因为这正是他们想要的。这恰恰是其阴险狡猾之处。他枪杀了一名警察，这阴险的狡猾，拜托。你知道的，他被克格勃洗脑了。我的意思是，不管怎样。是的。但你说得对，对吧？它确实提供了一种安心感。我的意思是，这正是阴谋论未曾明言的真相：它让人们觉得，尽管背后可能有吸血鬼般的蜥蜴人在操纵，但至少这能给你一些安慰，让你觉得人们知道自己在做什么，哪怕这是出于最恶毒的目的。但这也让你感觉良好，对吧？因为你看穿了它，所以你是光明势力的一员，你是抵抗力量的一部分，你看穿了邪恶的计划。所以这让你占了一点优势。你周围都是那些没有看穿的绵羊，这比觉得你生活在一个完全随机的世界里要舒服得多——在这个世界里，一块巨大的石头随时可能砸到你的头上并杀死你，而且毫无意义。我认为对于人们来说，缺乏意义是一件极其可怕的事情，不是吗？
blood-sucking lizards behind it at least that gives you some reassurance that people know what they're doing even if it's for the most malign purposes but also makes you feel good right because you've seen through it so you're one of the forces of light and you're part of the resistance you have seen through the the evil plan so that gives you a bit of an advantage you're surrounded by the sheep who haven't and that's much more comforting than thinking you live in an entirely random world where a big you know stone block might fall on your head at any moment and kill you and it has no meaning i think that's a terrifying thing, isn't it, for people? The lack of meaning.
历史必须有一个意义，而阴谋论恰好提供了一个。它们当然也可以发挥政治武器的作用。因为如果你能指控你的敌人卷入了某种阴谋，然后把自己塑造成揭露该阴谋的人，
There must be a meaning in history, and conspiracy theories provide one. And what they also can do, of course, is provide a political weapon. Because if you can accuse your enemies of being embroiled in a conspiracy, and then you cast yourself as the person who has exposed that conspiracy,
那么你就会成为当之无愧的英雄。你将——我能看出汤姆这是要往哪里扯了。是的。所以我们从20世纪60年代的美国无缝衔承到了公元前60年代的罗马。非常妙。这里有所有阴谋论的始祖，也就是喀提林阴谋。这是一个由一个阴谋诡计多端的罗马贵族喀提林（据称）所进行的阴谋，他打算接管罗马，雇佣高卢帮派在元老院谋杀他的政敌。这一阴谋被伟大的演说家西塞罗揭露，西塞罗的演讲为后人争相研究的政治修辞提供了模板。
then you become the hero of the hour. And you will- I can see where this is going with Tom. Yes. So we're seamlessly moving from 1960s America to 60s BC Rome. Very nice. With really the granddaddy of all conspiracy theories, which is the Catilinarium conspiracy, a conspiracy conducted by a shady Roman aristocrat called Catiline, supposedly, who was going to take over Rome, employ gangs of Gauls to murder his enemies in the Senate. is exposed by the great orator Cicero whose speeches provide a template for political rhetoric
而在西塞罗揭露喀提林阴谋的周围，从他发表这些演讲的那一刻起，就一直存在着一种黑暗的怀疑：也许西塞罗当时夸大其词了。直到今天，弄清这一点仍然是个问题，因为当然，我们手中只有西塞罗的供词。所以我们没有，你知道的，我们没有来自喀提林的反驳。我们只有西塞罗的演讲。从某种意义上说，这提供了一个模板，正是因为西塞罗的演讲极具影响力，它们某种程度上
that people have studied essentially ever since and floating around Cicero's exposure of this Catilinarian conspiracy has always been right from the very time that he gave these speeches the dark suspicion that perhaps Cicero was over-egging it. And it's still a problem today to work that out because, of course, we only have Cicero's accounts. So we don't have, you know, we don't have any counterblast from Catiline. So we only have Cicero's speeches. And in a sense, that provides the template, precisely because Cicero's speeches are so influential they kind
提供了一种如何书写拉丁语的典范。因此，在整个16世纪乃至17世纪，人们都在对此进行研究。我想这随后对人们（比如在17世纪的英国）对黑暗阴谋的戒备心产生了影响，而其中最明显、最耀眼的例子大概就是“天主教阴谋”（Popish Plot）。是的，“天主教阴谋”是一个极其迷人的事件，不是吗？我的意思是，那显然是一个时代，17世纪是一个充斥着阴谋的时代。我们几周前才刚讨论过17世纪。
of provide a model of how to write Latin so throughout the 16th and then into the 17th century this is being studied and I guess that then has an impact on the readiness of people say in in 17th century England to suspect dark conspiracies which had and the obvious I suppose the kind of glaring example of that is the Popish Plot. Yeah, the Popish Plot is a fascinating thing, isn't it? I mean, obviously that was an age, the 17th century is an age rich with conspiracies. I mean, we talked about the 17th century a few weeks ago.
但“天主教阴谋”是所有阴谋的始祖，因为在某种程度上，它是英国政治的基石。所以，向听众解释一下，那是查理二世统治的末期。是的。正如你所说，它的背景实际上是一系列被证明属实的阴谋，比如盖伊·福克斯。是的，盖伊·福克斯就是个典型的例子，不是吗？是的，这就是个经典的例子。所以——你注意到阴谋确实是有可能的。是的，提图斯·奥茨，这个天主教徒，
But the Popish Plot is the granddaddy, because in a way it's the foundation of British politics. So, just for the listeners, that's the end of Charles II's reign. Yes. As you say, it comes against a background actually of course of conspiracies that are proven to be true which guy fawkes um yeah guy fawkes is the classic one isn't it yeah it's the classic one so so you have you you've noted actually conspiracies are possible yeah and titus oats who is this catholic fellow, who says he has inside knowledge. He has been to training schools.
自称掌握了内幕消息。他去过培训学校。
He has mixed with Jesuits. He's been on the continent. So then he's recanted. He's come back to England. And he says, I know. And he has all these details. He appears to have all these details. He says, you know, and this is always the way that with conspiracy theories,
他与耶稣会士混在一起，去过欧洲大陆。然后他叛变了。他回到英国后说：我知道。他掌握了所有这些细节。他似乎掌握了所有这些细节。他说，你知道的——阴谋论总是这样，
that they have an inside man who has since repented who returns and says well you know i've seen the light i was a sinner but i now know all the ins and outs of the conspiracy i mean this is how you know anti-communism in 1950s america often where mccarthyism people would say i was a communist in the 30s i know how evil they are and i know that all university professors are communists well this is sort of how titus oates works he says i have this tremendous amount of knowledge i know there's a plot to kill the king um catholics are poised any moment to rise up over england um the jesuits have been plotting the whole thing and it falls on very fertile ground and because he seems to have this level of expertise, this inside knowledge, people believe it. And then there's this, he says, James, Duke of York, who is a Catholic,
它们都有一个曾背叛组织、如今改邪归正并返回的内部线人，宣称：“好吧，你知道的，我见过了光明，我曾经是个罪人，但我现在知道了阴谋的所有内情。”我的意思是，这就是19世纪50年代美国麦卡锡主义时期的反共主义运作的方式——人们会说：“我在30年代是个共产主义者，我知道他们有多邪恶，我知道所有的大学教授都是共产主义者。”嗯，提图斯·奥茨差不多就是这样运作的。他说：“我拥有数量惊人的内幕知识，我知道有一个谋杀国王的阴谋，天主教徒随时准备在英国发动起义，耶稣会士一直在策划这一切。”这番话落在了一块非常肥沃的土地上。而且因为他似乎具备这种专业水平、这种内部消息，人们便信以为真。然后还有，他说詹姆斯，约克公爵——一个天主教徒，
who is Charles II's brother and heir, he says, they're going to put him on the throne, make him king, he's a Catholic. And you have that creates this sort of big political crisis where you have the Tories and the Whigs, the Whigs who want to kick James out of the line of succession, the Tories who want to keep him. So in a sense, you can trace all British politics back to the, I mean, it's slightly sort of tangential, but you can trace it all back to the sort of paranoia of the Popish plot. But I mean, it gets exposed, doesn't it? I mean, Charles II never really believes it. And in due course, I mean, Titus Oates is condemned as a fraud. He's made to stand on the pillory every year, whipped through the
即查理二世的弟弟和继承人——他们打算把他扶上王位，让他当国王，因为他是个天主教徒。这引发了一场巨大的政治危机，形成了托利党和辉格党。辉格党想要把詹姆斯排除在继承顺位之外，而托利党则想让他保留继承权。所以从某种程度上说，你可以把所有的英国政治都追溯到——我的意思是，这有点离题，但你完全可以把它追溯到天主教阴谋的那种偏情。不过，这件事最终还是被揭穿了，不是吗？我的意思是，查理二世从来没有真正相信过。后来，提图斯·奥茨被谴责为骗子。他被罚每年在颈手枷上示众，并在街头遭受鞭笞。但它的影响挥之不去。我的意思是，我认为正是在这段时期，在提图斯·奥茨煽起的恐慌期间，天主教士被禁止进入议会两院。这种情况一直持续到了19世纪初，所以这产生了切实可测的影响。哦，确实如此。查理其实并不相信。他问了一些问题——有时会问一些奥茨答错的问题，而查理很清楚奥茨在某个特定时间根本不在那个地方，他能看出其中的一些错误。但他处于
streets. But the effects of it linger. I mean, I think it's during this period, during the kind of scare that Titus Oates has whipped up, that Catholics get banned from both the Houses of Parliament. And that's something that lasts right the way up to the early 19th century so this has measurable effects oh it did charles didn't really believe it he asked you know people asked sometimes asked questions that he got wrong and charles kind of knew he hadn't been in such and such a place at such and such a time and he could he could spot some of the the the mistakes but he's in But he was in a difficult position. He wasn't in really a position to sort of expose it straight away. And it actually took a long, as you say, it did get exposed,
一个艰难的处境。他实际上并没有处于那种可以立刻将其揭穿的位置。正如你所说，这件事确实被揭露了，
but it took a few years. And it also, as you say, had measurable effects. So conspiracy theories really matter. I mean, the fact that all politics in Britain, you can argue, stems from a conspiracy theory tells you, I think, something about politics as well, that there's always an element of conspiracy theory in politics. No matter how democratic and sane, there's always this...
但花了几年的时间。而且正如你所说，它产生了切实可测的影响。所以阴谋论确实至关重要。我的意思是，英国的所有政治都可以说起源于一个阴谋论，这本身就向你说明了一些关于政治的道理：政治中总是包含着阴谋论的成分。无论它多么民主和理智，总会存在这种……
Don't you think that people always are talking about elites and corruption and shadowy networks that i mean you've seen this so much recently well yes i mean i suppose essentially at an election what the electorate is being asked to decide is which which shadowy organization do you want to get rid of yeah i mean essentially that's what it comes down to you you you know you decide to vote for one party or the other based on on your conviction that that when one party says the other party will ruin the country that's right yeah yeah you're basically buying to a narrative don't you the two part the two main parties give you a narrative in which they are the representatives of the people and the other guys are the cruel malevolent
难道你不觉得人们总是在谈论精英、腐败和隐秘的网络吗？我的意思是，你最近经常看到这种情况。嗯，是的，我的意思是，我想本质上一场选举中，选民被要求决定的就是：你想除掉哪一个隐秘的组织？是的，我的意思是，本质上这就是归结到的问题。你决定投票给这个党还是那个党，是基于这样一种信念：当一个党派说另一个党派会毁了国家时，那是对的。对，是的。你基本上是在买入一种叙事，不是吗？两大主要政党给你提供了一种叙事，其中他们是人民的代表，而另一方则是残酷、恶毒、冷酷无情的精英，正密谋与他们在媒体中的朋友一起摧毁英国。我的意思是，你看，天哪，你在过去10年里看了太多次了。嗯，是的，我们绝对在脱欧时看到了这一点。两方完全在捏造这样一种观念：他们的敌人排成一列，
um callous elite who are plotting with their friends in the media to destroy britain i mean you see this my god you've seen this so much in the last 10 years well yes we absolutely with brexit absolutely um both sides completely kind of manufacturing the notion that their enemies are ranked in yeah there'll be lines of conspiracies and funded by foreign governments and all kinds yes i mean complete and i guess that that a further corollary of that is um something that is made play with in i guess the great novel about conspiracy theories fuko's pendulum by um alberto echo which essentially takes every great conspiracy theory
全都是阴谋，由外国政府资助，诸如此类。是的，完全是……我猜其进一步的推论是——翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco）关于阴谋论的伟大长篇小说《傅科摆》（Foucault's Pendulum）中就拿这一点大做文章。该书本质上把历史上每一个伟大的阴谋论——圣殿骑士团、玫瑰十字会以及所有人——全都打包进了一个超级阴谋论中，纯粹是为了好玩。我的意思是，那是一群大学教授和记者干的，然后他们发现自己创造出来的幻想竟然成真了。我认为这太有趣了，因为你在历史上一次又一次地看到这一点：人们把恐惧投射到他们的敌人身上，而结果往往是，他们的敌人最终真的具备了被投射到他们身上的那些特质。嗯，这就是水门事件的例子，不是吗？你知道的，人们……是的，是的，是的。但我的意思是，其中最引人入胜的例子是13世纪初发生在法国南部的阿尔比十字军东征（Albigensian Crusade），我们现在倾向于称之为卡特里派（Cathars），尽管“卡特里派”这个词直到19世纪后期才被用来称呼阿尔比派，这说明这些阴谋论需要多长时间才能成形。但本质上，这个想法是——《傅科摆》也拿这个做文章——在法国南部，有一个隐秘的异端教会，它是按照天主教教会的模子建立的。这是一个二元论教会，也就是说它认为存在一个善神和一个恶神，他们拥有竞争的、平等的权力。阿尔比十字军东征的发起，据说是为了斩草除根、消灭这个存在于想象中的教会。它给法国南部这个富庶文明的核心地带带来了无与伦比的毁灭和血腥。它实质上给宗教裁判所加了速，为贯穿整个中世纪历史的异端树立了模板。然而，据我们所知，实际上这个隐秘教会的想法根本不存在——
in history, so the Knight's Temper and the Rosicrucians and everybody, and bundles it up into one super conspiracy theory, just for fun, really. I mean, it's a kind of a group of professors who do it, and journalists, and then they discover that they've actually, that what they've created as a fantasy comes true. And I think it it's so interesting because you do see that again and again through history um that people project fears onto their enemies and it can happen that their enemies will ultimately take on the lineaments of what is being projected onto them well that's the watergate example isn't it you know people yes yes yes but i mean i think the the most fascinating example of that is with the albigensian crusade in okay the early 13th century which we would now tend to call the
那纯属幻想，是捏造出来的。阴谋论改变历史进程的威力在此得到了戏剧般的生动说明，尤其是人们仍然倾向于认为确实存在过卡特里派。所以卡特里派根本不存在，这基本上就是你想说的？不，我的意思是，确实曾有一些人，他们对基督教信仰的态度在几个世纪前绝对是正统的。他们不是博戈米尔派（Bogomils）吗，汤姆？不，他们不是。这太令人失望了。不，所以所有这些人物——认为存在隐秘的异端网络在密谋、聚会并将阴谋传播到整个欧洲的这种想法——
cathars although the word cathars is only applied to the al Albigensians in the late 19th century, which shows how long these conspiracy theories take to work out. But essentially, the idea is that, and again, Foucault's pendulum makes play with this, that there is in the south of France, there is a shadowy heretical church, which is modelled on the Catholic Church. And it is a dualist, so it believes that there are, you know, there is a God who is good and there is a God who is evil and they have rival powers, equal powers. And the Albigensian Crusade is launched to extirpate, supposedly, this fantastical church that exists. And it brings devastation and bloodshed kind of beyond compare into the heart of this rich civilisation of southern France. It essentially turbocharges the Inquisition. It establishes a template for heresy that runs throughout medieval history. And yet, as far as we can tell, actually, this idea of the shadowy chair did not you know it was a fantasy it was made up
完全是教会的幻想。但基本上，他们对待阿尔比派的方式就相当于对待社会渣滓（deplorables）。这些人被教会精英圈子里对正统观念的理解、对什么是对什么是错的发展步伐抛在了后面。所以本质上，他们是在针对那些略知一二、却固守着对基督教早已过时的正确理解的人。但这太吸引人了，以至于它继续构建着小说、电影，甚至整个旅游业。我正要说呢，两年前我去朗格多克（Languedoc）度假，我们参观了所有的卡特里派城堡。
and the potency of conspiracy theories to change the course of history is so dramatically illustrated by that not least in the way that people still tend to think that you know that there were such things as catharsis so the catharsis didn't exist that's what you're basically saying no uh that there were people who who held um attitudes towards their christian faith that had been absolutely orthodox a couple of centuries before are they not bogomils tom no they're not oh this is very disappointing no so so all of those figures um kind of the the idea that there are shadowy networks of of heretics conspiring and and and meeting up and spreading their conspiracy across Europe.
我的意思是，留在我的记忆中最深刻的是，他们有一个关于最后一个卡特里派信徒的大型展览，那个人叫贝利巴斯特（Bellybast）。对于一个在历史上有如此英雄般殉道角色的人来说，这个名字听起来稍微有点不幸。他们有所有关于卡特里派的东西，而你却在告诉我朗格多克旅游局在兜售谎言？我认为他们在兜售一种幻想。这是一种相当赚钱的幻想。我们在朗格多克的听众正成千上万地流失。这当然也有真实成分的元素，正如我们所说，阴谋论必须把人们内心深处知道是真的事情编织进去。但我也认为，最让人着迷的是，当宗教裁判所开始介入，开始审讯那些被他们指控犯有这种异端罪的人时，那些被指控的人开始说：“好吧，是的，我的确有罪。”所以这很有趣，事情就是这样运作的。他们强加了一种模式，这实际上和——这是一个非常奇怪的对比——这让我想起奥斯曼帝国崩解之后，人们在巴尔干半岛走来走去，问人们：“你是保加利亚人、马其顿人、塞尔维亚人还是别的什么？”人们通常并不知道，他们答不上来，于是审讯者就会把某种身份强加给他们。人们基本上只能逆来顺受，因为如果他们不知道、答不上来，他们就会被枪毙。然后他们就真的变成了那些人。所以你基本上——这通常就是这些事情运作的方式，不是吗？人们把一种身份强加给某个事物，强加一种模式，最后人们真的活成了那个样子。所以人们把卡特里派的模型强加给法国西南部，
It's a complete fantasy of the church. But basically what they're dealing with with Albigensians is the equivalent of deplorables. It's people who've been left behind by the way that in elite circles in the church, orth notions of orthodoxy notions of what is right and wrong has developed and so essentially they're going into white people who know a lot who who are clinging to outdated right understanding of what christianity is but it's it's but it's so appealing that it continues to structure novels and yeah films and and in fact the entire tourist industry i was just about to say two years ago ago we went to the Languedoc on holiday and we went to all the Cathar castles.
现在法国西南部欣然接受了它。所以人们买入阴谋论，最终变成了人们所恐惧的那个阴谋本身。嗯，我认为这是一个令人激动的音符，我们可以借此稍作休息。当多米尼克和我重新校准你手机上的微型摄像头和你血液中的微型芯片时，我们休息一下，马上回来。
I mean, the one that sticks in my mind is when they've got a huge exhibition about the last Cathar who was a man called Bellybast. Very slightly unfortunate name, I think, for somebody with such a sort of heroic sort of martyrdom role in history. And they had all this stuff about the cathars and you're telling me that their long dock tourist board is peddling a lie i think they're peddling a fantasy it's quite a lucrative fantasy we're losing listeners in long dot by the you know by the thousand and which of course does have elements of truth i mean as we've said conspiracy theories have to weave in
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。血液中的微型芯片.com，即 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，这是一个由一个不知致力于带来什么可怕事件、或者其实什么也没有的隐秘集团资助的播客。现在，阴谋论这个话题显然是人们极为感兴趣的，因为当我们提到这期播客的主题时，你们在推特上给我们发了大量的推文。所以让我们来看看其中的一小部分。显然，我们只能看一小部分。至于那些我们没看的，我们直接扔进垃圾桶了，因为我们只能看一小部分——
things that people kind of know is true but also i think what's fascinating about that when the inquisition start to move in and they start to interrogate um people that they're accusing of this heresy people who are accused of it starts okay yeah all right yes i am guilty of it and so that's interesting that's kind of how it works so they're sort of imposing a pattern so that's actually not unlike this is a very weird comparison but that's a this is a the what that reminds me of is after the ottoman empire fell apart and people would go around the balkans and they would say to people are you a bulgarian a macedonian a serbian or whatever and people often didn't know they didn't have an answer and they would sort of impose an identity
至于那些我们没看的，我们直接扔进了垃圾桶，因为我们是一个邪恶阴谋的一部分。是的，这是一个阴谋，没错，这是一个阴谋。所以，好吧，第一条来自比尔·琼斯（Bill Jones）。
on them which people basically put up with because they'd be shot if they didn't know, they didn't have an answer and they would sort of impose an identity on them which people basically put up with because they'd be shot if they didn't. And then they became those things. So you're basically, and that's often how these things work, isn't it? That people project an identity onto something, they project a pattern and then people end up living up to it. So people imposed the sort of Catharism model on the south-west of France
我认为这实际上从某种程度上来说，它是历史上最黑暗、最重要的一个阴谋论，也是那个怎么也消灭不了的阴谋论。比尔·琼斯写道：“过去和现在的阴谋论中，都有一条长长的反犹太主义主线：血祭诽谤、《锡安长老会纪要》、德雷福斯事件、与历史瘟疫的联系、关于索罗斯的疯狂言论。没完没了。”那是悲哀地真实，不是吗，多米尼克？是的，这是终极的阴谋论，不是吗？这是那种元阴谋论（ur-conspiracy），尽管我认为它随着时间推移发生了变化。所以中世纪的反犹太主义以及那种血祭诽谤之类的东西，它并不具备自19世纪末尤其是20世纪以来所呈现的那种元素。那是什么呢？也就是犹太人在恶魔学中的地位从最底层变成了最高层。所以在中世纪时期，他们显然是局外人，遭受过大屠杀什么的；但在20世纪，典型的纳粹阴谋论显然是：犹太人不是局外人，他们是终极的内部人，
and now the south-west of France happily embraces it. So people buying into conspiracy theories becoming the very conspiracy that people dread. Well, a thrilling note, I think, on which to just have a short pause. While Dominic and I recalibrate the mini cameras on your phones and the microchips in your blood, we'll be back after this break.
在幕后控制着媒体、金融、大企业以及所有这些东西，他们策划了“背后捅刀”之类的一切。所以反犹太主义随着时间不断适应调整，这就是它如此成功的一个原因，令人悲哀的是，正如我们所见，它并没有消失。我的意思是，这是一件非常不可思议的事情。我记得大约20岁的时候，有人跟我谈起英国的反犹太主义，谈到他们的一本书。我的经纪人说他当时正代理一个叫安东尼·朱利叶斯（Anthony Julius）的人，这个人写了一本关于英国反犹太主义的大部头书，他曾与出版商开会，而出版商却对他说：“好吧，英国根本没有反犹太主义。为什么要出一本关于不存在的东西的书呢？”当时我想，你知道吗，英国大概真的没有什么反犹太主义。我的意思是，我怎么能错得如此离谱呢？我绝不会预料到过去十年左右会卷土重来。这简直令人沮丧到难以置信。它就像是一个九头蛇。我甚至在想，犹太人在历史上所扮演的角色之一，是不是提供了一种——有点像天主教教会那样——
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. the microchips in your blood.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history the podcast paid for by a shadowy cabal committed to bringing about who knows what terrible events, or indeed not. Now, the topic of conspiracy theories is obviously one that people are incredibly interested in, because you've sent us a vast number of tweets when we mentioned on Twitter the subject for this podcast. So let's take a look at just a few of them. And obviously, we're only going to be able to look at a few of them. And the ones that we're not looking at, we're binning them because we're only going to be able to look at a few of them um and the ones that we're not looking at we're we're binning them for because we're part of a sinister conspiracy yeah it's a plot yes it's a plot it's a plot so um okay so the first one is from bill jones
对真正权力所在的一种荒诞的讽刺。所以血祭诽谤——认为犹太人绑架基督教儿童并谋杀他们、将他们的血混合起来作为对弥撒的一种荒诞模仿——显然在某种程度上是对中世纪占主导地位的机构——教会权力的一种评注。
um and i think it's actually in a way it's, it's historically the darkest and most significant conspiracy theory of the lot, the one that just refuses to die. Bill James writes, a long strand of anti-Semitism in past and present conspiracy theories, blood libel, protocols of the elders of Zion, Dreyfus, linkages to historical plagues, COVID mad stuff about Soros. It goes on and on. That is mournfully true, is it not, Dominic? Yeah, it's the ultimate conspiracy theory, isn't it? It's this sort of ur-conspiracy theory, although I think it's changed over time. So medieval anti-Semitism and that sort of blood libel and stuff, it didn't quite have the element that it has had since the late 19th century and particularly the 20th century which is the idea that so the jews went from being as it were bottom dog to top dog in the sort of in the the demonology so they were
从某种意义上说，这与19世纪末到20世纪（乃至21世纪）的一种情况非常相似：犹太人控制国际金融的这种观念，在某种程度上是对人们对金融焦虑的一种评注。是的，这就是那种焦虑：我们被我们所不理解的、恐怖的数字屏幕所控制，被算法、被庞大而匿名的机构所控制。从某种程度上说，如果我们能把这与犹太人或任何人联系起来，我们就能为这些空白的屏幕赋予一张脸。那么在某种程度上，我们就在某种程度上人性化了它。绝对是这样。我认为这就是为什么——这显然是反犹太主义在第一次世界大战后在德国如此成功的原因之一：如果你是——假设你是一个中产阶级下层的德国人，可能拥有一家小商店什么的，你眼睁睁地看着自己的世界被第一次世界大战、战争结束时的革命、20世纪20年代的恶性通货膨胀以及大萧条的冲击所摧毁——这些你并不真正理解也无法控制的庞大全球力量——反犹太主义给你提供了一种理解这一切的方式，它给了你代罪羔羊，而这正是人们在任何时候都想要的——寻找代罪羔羊的渴望永远不会消亡。而犹太人是最古老、最执着的代罪羔羊。因此，完全有理由把纳粹主义描述为一种夺取权力并将其武器化的阴谋论。是的，绝对如此。所以我想纳粹主义——你读《我的奋斗》，《我的奋斗》就是一个巨大的阴谋论，不是吗？纳粹主义的吸引力在于，德国被出卖了，它从内部被破坏了。我的意思是，这是一个庞大无比的阴谋论。这大概也就是为什么它滋生了如此多的阴谋论，为什么会有人相信鲁道夫·赫斯（Rudolf Hess）飞往英国执行希特勒授权的秘密和平任务，或者希特勒在地堡中幸存下来，或者安格拉·默克尔是希特勒的后代并密谋建立第四帝国。这些东西在非常肥沃的土壤中生根发芽，
outsiders obviously in you know medieval period when they suffered pogroms or whatever but in the 20th century you know they're obviously the classic nazi conspiracy theory is that the jews are not outsiders they are the ultimate insiders who are you know controlling the media and finance and big business and all this kind of thing and they've orchestrated the stab in the back and all the rest of it so anti-semitism has been has adapted over time and that's one reason it's been so successful sad to say and as we see it hasn't gone away i mean it's an extraordinary thing i remember about 20 years ago somebody saying to me um about anti-semitism in britain about a book they were they were my agent said he was
因为纳粹主义本身就是一个阴谋论。正如许多非常狂热、略显极端——或者不是略显极端，而是极其极端的政治运动一样，我认为，正如我们之前所说，任何形式的政治总是存在着变成阴谋论的危险。没错。这也是自由主义中间派的真实写照，不是吗？那种担心纳粹正潜伏在暗处、等待接管政权的紧张感。我的意思是，这也是偏执风格的一种表现，对吧？我认为是的，实际上。我认为没有任何一个政治领域能对这种偏执风格免疫。我的意思是，你曾有多少次置身于这样的对话中：有人对你说，选举被操纵了，选举被偷了，托利党、工党或其他什么党派以及他们在媒体中的权势朋友正在对公众撒谎并给公众洗脑？我的意思是，如果你参与政治对话，你就会一周又一周地听到这种言论，它永远不会消失。好啦，汤姆，在我们将听众彻底出卖给奥利·辛普森（Ollie Simpson）之前，我们先继续。奥利·辛普森说：“提图斯·奥茨声称摩德纳的玛丽（即未来国王詹姆斯二世的妻子）的秘书与法国耶稣会士勾结。他当时信口胡扯，但居然说中了。”好吧，这是真的。所以奥茨确实猜对了一些事情。阴谋论往往就是这样：里面包含着一些真实内核。它们有一些微小的元素确实被猜中了，然后这似乎就暗示着其他所有事情也全都是对的。我认为有趣的地方就在于此：
representing a guy called anthony julius who had written this big book about anti-semitism in britain and he'd had meetings with publishers at which publishers had said, well, there is no anti-Semitism in Britain. So why publish this book on something that doesn't exist? And at the time, I thought, you know what, there probably isn't really much anti-Semitism in Britain. I mean, how wrong could I have been? You know, I would never have anticipated the resurgence in the last 10 years or so. It's unbelievably depressing. It's kind of like a hydra. And I wonder actually whether one of the things that Jews historically, the role that they've played is to offer a kind of, a bit like with the Catholic Church,
如果你跟一个阴谋论者争论，由于他们有强迫倾向，按定义，他们对这个主题的了解就会比你多。他们总是能把你绕进去，说：“啊，但是你看这个，看那个，看别的。”但对奥茨来说，这显然是一个大礼。他的一个猜测居然被证实是正确的。
a grotesque parody of the control of where power authentically is. So the blood libel, the idea that Jews are seizing Christian children and murdering them and mixing their blood up for a kind of grotesque parody of the mass is obviously in a way a kind of commentary on the power of the church, which is the dominant institution in the Middle Ages.
这是对权力真正所在的一种怪诞的嘲讽。所以血祭 libel，即犹太人绑架基督教儿童并杀害他们，将其血混合起来用于一种对弥撒的怪诞模仿，在某种程度上显然是对中世纪主导机构教会权力的一种评论。
And in a way, there is a kind of similar way that that in the in the late 19th century into the 20th century and you know still in the 21st century the idea that jews control international finance is in a way a commentary about people's anxieties about finance yeah it's it's it's the anxiety that um we are controlled by terrifying screens of figures that we don't understand, by algorithms, by vast anonymous institutions. And in a way, if we can associate that with Jews or with whoever, we can put a face to these blank screens. Then in a way, we're kind of humanizing it right exactly and i think that's why i mean that's obviously one of the reasons that anti-semitism was so successful in germany after the first world war is that if you're you know let's say
从某种意义上说，在19世纪末到20世纪，以及你知道的，甚至在21世纪，犹太人控制国际金融的观点，在某种程度上是对人们对金融焦虑的一种评论。是的，这就是那种焦虑，我们被我们不理解的、可怕的数字屏幕所控制，被算法控制，被庞大的匿名机构控制。从某种程度上说，如果我们能把这与犹太人或任何人联系起来，我们就能给这些空白屏幕安上一张脸。然后从某种程度上说，我们在某种程度上将其人性化了，对，完全是这样。我认为这就是为什么——显然这也是反犹太主义在第一次世界大战后的德国如此成功的原因之一，如果你是一个，比方说
a lower middle class german who maybe owns a small shop or something you have seen your world destroyed by the first world war by the revolution at the end of the war the hyper inflation of the 1920s then the shock of the great depression these massive forces global forces that you don't really understand and can't control and you know anti-semitism gives you a way of making sense of that it gives you scapegoats which is what people always want in you know that will never die the search for scapegoats. And the Jews are the oldest and most sort of persistent scapegoats of all. And so there is a case for describing Nazism as a kind of conspiracy theory that takes power and weaponises itself. Yeah, absolutely. So I think Nazism, I mean, you read Mein Kampf, Mein Kampf
一个中下阶层的德国人，可能拥有一家小商店之类的，你眼睁睁看着你的世界被第一次世界大战、战争结束时的革命、20世纪20年代的恶性通货膨胀，然后是大萧条的冲击所摧毁，这些巨大的力量，你并不真正理解也无法控制的全球力量。你知道，反犹太主义给你提供了一种理解这一切的方式，它给你提供了替罪羊，这正是人们一直想要的，你知道，这种对替罪羊的寻找永远不会消亡。而犹太人是最古老、最持久的替罪羊。因此，有理由将纳粹主义描述为一种掌握了权并将其武器化的阴谋论。是的，绝对是这样。所以我觉得纳粹主义，我的意思是，你去读《我的奋斗》，《我的奋斗》
is a massive conspiracy theory, isn't it? And the appeal of Nazism, which is that, you know, Germany has been betrayed, that it has been undermined from within. I mean, it is a colossal conspiracy theory. And that's probably why it's bred so many conspiracy theories, why you have people who believed that, you know, Rudolf Hess was flying to Britain as a secret mission to make peace, authorised by Hitler, or that Hitler survived the bunker, or that Angela Merkel is Hitler's descendant and plotting to bring about a fourth Reich. I mean, those things have grown in very fertile assault
是一个巨大的阴谋论，不是吗？而纳粹主义的吸引力在于，你知道，德国被出卖了，它从内部被瓦解了。我的意思是，这是一个庞大的阴谋论。这大概也就是为什么它滋生了如此多的阴谋论，为什么会有这样的人：他们相信鲁道夫·赫斯飞往英国是一项由希特勒授权的秘密和平使命，或者希特勒在地堡中幸存下来，或者安格拉·默克尔是希特勒的后代并密谋建立第四帝国。我的意思是，这些东西在非常肥沃的土壤中滋生
because Nazism was a conspiracy theory. As a lot of very passionate, slightly extreme, or slightly extreme, very extreme political movements are, I think there's always, as we said before, there's always that danger with any form of politics that it turns into conspiracy theory. Right. And that's true of kind of liberal centrism as well, isn't it? The nervousness that Nazis are kind of lurking in the winds,
因为纳粹主义本身就是一种阴谋论。就像许多非常激进的、略显极端的，或者说极端的政治运动一样，我认为，正如我们之前所说的那样，任何形式的政治都有可能变成阴谋论，这始终是一种危险。没错。自由主义中间派也是如此，对吧？那种担心纳粹潜伏在暗处、
waiting to take over. I mean, that's also an expression of the paranoid style, isn't it? I think it is, actually. I don't think there's any area of politics that is immune from that kind of paranoid style. I mean, how often, you know, how often have you been in a conversation where somebody has said to you, the election was rigged, the election was stolen, the Tories or Labour or whoever it might be, and their powerful friends in the media are lying to the public and brainwashing the public. I mean, you'll hear that, you know, if you have conversations about
随时准备接管政权的神经质，这也是偏执狂风格的一种表现，不是吗？我认为确实如此。我认为没有任何政治领域能免受这种偏执狂风格的影响。我的意思是，你经历过多少次这样的对话：有人对你说，选举被操纵了，选举被偷了，保守党或工党或其他什么党，以及他们在媒体中有权有势的朋友正在对公众撒谎并给公众洗脑。我的意思是，如果你去谈论
politics, you will hear that week in, week out, and it never goes away. Right, Tom, let's move on before we betray our listeners completely to Ollie Simpson. Ollie Simpson says, Titus Oates claimed Mary of Modena's secretary, that's the, Mary of Modena was the wife of James, the future James II, Oates claimed her secretary was in cahoots with the French Jesuits. He was spouting BS off the top of his head, but was right. Well, this is true. So Oates did get some things right. And that's often the way with conspiracy theories is that there are grains of truth. There are sort of little elements that they do get right. And that seem to then suggest that everything else is right. And I think that's the interesting thing,
政治，你会周复一周地听到这种言论，而且它永远不会消失。好了，汤姆，在我们彻底背叛听众投奔奥利·辛普森之前，我们继续吧。奥利·辛普森说，蒂塔斯·奥茨声称摩德纳的玛丽的秘书——也就是摩德纳的玛丽是詹姆斯的妻子，未来的詹姆斯二世——奥茨声称她的秘书与法国耶稣会士勾结。他当时是在信口胡说，但却说对了。好吧，这是真的。所以奥茨确实说对了一些事情。阴谋论往往就是这样，里面总会有一些真实的成分。它们总有一些小元素确实猜对了，然后这似乎就暗示其他一切也都是对的。我认为有趣的是，
that if you argue with a conspiracy theorist, by definition, because they're obsessive, they will know more about the subject than you will. And they'll always sort of run rings around you and say, ah, but look at this, look at that, look at the other. But obviously for Oates, this was, you know, this was a gift, basically. One of his guesses turned out to be correct.
如果你和一个阴谋论者争论，根据定义，因为他们是偏执狂，他们对这个主题的了解会比你多。他们总是能把你绕进去，说，啊，但是你看这个，看那个，看别的。但对奥茨来说，基本上这简直是一份大礼。他的一次瞎猫碰上死耗子竟然猜对了。
And the Jesuits, I suppose, were plotting against England in a way. I mean, there were plots against the life of Elizabeth I and James I and so on. Maybe for a conspiracy theory to kind of go viral, as it were, and actually have a measurable impact on the politics of the day, it does need that leavening of fact. There is no evidence at all that the royal family are lizards, for instance. And so that's why it just remains a kind of thing people laugh at. Whereas the idea that the Russians influenced the Brexit vote, there's enough evidence for that, that it's actually had kind of political traction and therefore a measurable political impact on discourse.
我想，耶稣会士在某种程度上也在密谋反对英格兰。我的意思是，曾有过谋杀伊丽莎白一世和詹姆斯一世等人的阴谋。也许阴谋论要像那样“病毒式传播”，并在当今政治中产生切实的影响，它确实需要事实作为酵母。例如，没有任何证据表明王室成员是蜥蜴人。这就是为什么这只是一种人们当作笑料的事情。然而，关于俄罗斯干预英国脱欧公投的说法，有足够的证据表明它确实获得了政治上的关注，并因此对政治话语产生了可测量的政治影响。
Or the JFK. This would be an example of it, yes. The JFK assassination, the CIA did have assassination plots, not against American presidents, but against foreign leaders. So, you know, it's not also that Oswald was in he was in Russia I mean that is quite odd yeah I mean I know that you just counted it with your ragged skepticism but I mean that is quite odd yeah and of course you know um all these things and it's like any political narrative a political narrative only takes hold if if people can recognise some things in it. And the Popish plot, say, would not have taken hold unless there was some element of truth,
或者肯尼迪遇刺案。这就是一个例子，是的。肯尼迪遇刺案中，中情局确实有暗杀计划，不是针对美国总统，而是针对外国领导人。所以，你知道的，奥斯华当时在俄罗斯也不是没有疑点，我的意思是这挺奇怪的，对吧？我的意思是，我知道你用你那残存的怀疑态度反驳了这一点，但我的意思是这确实挺奇怪的，对吧？当然，你知道的，所有这些事情，就像任何政治叙事一样，只有当人们能在其中认出某些东西时，政治叙事才能站住脚。比如，如果没有某些真实成分的话，阴谋论般的“阴谋”是不会站住脚的，
that there were Catholic powers that didn't like England, and there were people in the Catholic Church who wanted to re-Catholicise England and all the rest of it. Against that, we must say that there are certain conspiracy theories that are clearly not true, but develop because people have a stake in them and we come back to the blood libel with one from Daniel Pearl who talks about William of Norwich and the blood libel an evil conspiracy theory that still affects people to this day through Chaucer etc so the monk in his tale talks about it now William of Norwich, this is the origins of the blood libel. And he is, um, a young boy who vanishes in a wood outside Norwich in 1144. And then he gets hyped up as a martyr, someone
即存在不喜欢英格兰的天主教势力，天主教教会中也有人希望让英格兰重新天主教化，诸如此类。与此相对，我们必须说，某些阴谋论显然不是真的，但它们的滋生是因为人们在其中有切身利益，我们又回到了丹麦·珀尔（Daniel Pearl）提到的血祭诽谤，他谈到了诺维奇的威廉（William of Norwich）和血祭诽谤——这是一个邪恶的阴谋论，通过乔叟等人的作品至今仍影响着人们——因此乔叟在他的故事中谈到了这一点。现在，诺维奇的威廉，这就是血祭诽谤的起源。他是一个年轻男孩，于1144年在诺维奇郊外的一片树林里失踪。然后他被炒作成一个烈士，一个
who's been murdered by the Jews as a Christian. And the thing that's interesting about this, clearly it's not true he wasn't murdered the Jews were not interested in using his blood or anything like that but it gets hyped up because there is a need in Norwich Cathedral for a martyr or a saint and they don't really have one and so this guy Thomas of Monmouth who essentially writes the hagiography of William of Norwich, he has a huge stake. I mean, he's interested in doing it because this will then provide for pilgrims coming to the shrine of the murdered saint. And that is also a crucial part of conspiracy theories, isn't it? That they take off when they fill maybe uh yeah people's
被犹太人当作基督徒谋杀的人。有趣的是，显然这不是真的，他没有被谋杀，犹太人对使用他的鲜血之类的事情不感兴趣，但这件事被大肆炒作，因为诺维奇大教堂需要一个烈士或圣人，而他们实际上没有这样一个人物，所以这个名叫托马斯·蒙茅斯（Thomas of Monmouth）的家伙，他基本上撰写了诺维奇的威廉的圣徒传记，他有着巨大的利益。我的意思是，他对此很感兴趣，因为这随后将为来被谋杀的圣人神龛朝圣的朝圣者提供便利。这也是阴谋论中至关重要的一部分，不是吗？当它们填补了某种——是的——人们的
needs it's you know you've got a gap you need to fill it with something and this is the most baneful example of a lot because in a way i mean this is kind of the most shameful english invention um it it begins with william of norwich and then it gets kind of turbocharged with them with hugh of lincoln who's this again this little boy who vanishes and supposedly is murdered a century later. And it's kind of the most shameful English invention of all time. Wow, that's a big claim. But Tom, you know what? It's such an interesting thing there is that conspiracy, which I hadn't thought of until you mentioned this about Norwich needing a martyr. Conspiracy theories are lucrative.
需求时，它们就会腾飞。你知道的，你有一个空白，你需要用某种东西来填补它，而这是许多例子中最具毒害性的一例，因为在某种程度上，我的意思是，这是最可耻的英国发明……它始于诺维奇的威廉，然后随着林肯的小休（Hugh of Lincoln）而“涡轮增压”，这又是那个失踪并据称在一个世纪后被谋杀的小男孩。这可以说是史上最可耻的英国发明。哇，这口气可真大。不过，汤姆，你知道吗？其中最有趣的一点是，由于诺维奇需要一个烈士，我之前在你提到这一点之前没想到过这个。阴谋论是能赚钱的。
I mean, the JFK conspiracy theory has generated so much income for so many writers, and indeed, you know, Oliver Stone and his film, that conspiracy theories are an industry in and of themselves. I mean, they generate, they literally generate merchandise. And that's an interesting element to it. Now let's move on to the next one, because I think there's a couple of things I want to say about this. It's from a fellow called Michael Taylor, who has written a book called The Interest,
我的意思是，肯尼迪的阴谋论为那么多作家，以及奥利弗·斯通和他的电影带来了如此多的收入，以至于阴谋论本身就是一个产业。我的意思是，它们会产生，它们字面意义上会产生周边商品。这是一个有趣的因素。现在让我们进入下一个话题，因为我觉得关于这个我还有几点想说。这来自一个叫迈克尔·泰勒（Michael Taylor）的家伙，他写过一本书叫《利益》（The Interest），
which is all about the defence of slavery. So he's actually, although he doesn't mention this in his tweet, he's written a book about a network that did exist, a network of slave owners who are a network of slave owners who place articles in magazines like The Spectator and do influence votes in the House of Commons. He doesn't call them a conspiracy. I mean, he calls them a lobby. And his book is actually a model of how to write about a network
这本书讲的全是关于为奴隶制辩护的事。所以他实际上——尽管他在推文中没有提到这一点——写了一本关于一个确实存在的网络（一个奴隶主网络）的书，这个奴隶主网络在《旁观者》等杂志上发表文章，并确实影响了下议院的投票。他没有称他们为阴谋集团。我的意思是，他称他们为游说集团。他的书实际上是如何在不屈服于阴谋论的情况下书写一个网络的典范。
without succumbing to conspiracy theory. But anyway, he says the illuminati so this is a sort of slightly freemasons-ish group um uh very popular in germany and he says conservatives in england in 1790s were convinced they caused the french revolution one behind the 1798 irish rebellion we even stopped reading kant for five years immanuel kant the german philosopher because he was suspected of being one in brackets he says i have published on all this and actually it's not just the illuminati that people blame it's also the freemasons there's a huge thing of people blaming the french revolution on the freemasons and again there's a slight
无论如何，他说光明会——这是一种有点像共济会的组织——在1790年代的德国非常受欢迎，他说1790年代英格兰的保守党坚信是他们引发了法国大革命，他们是1798年爱尔兰叛乱的幕后黑手，我们甚至有五年时间停止阅读康德（伊曼努尔·康德，这位德国哲学家），因为他被怀疑是其中一员。他在括号里说：“我发表过关于这一切的文章，实际上人们指责的不仅仅是光明会，还有共济会，人们把法国大革命归咎于共济会的现象非常普遍。”同样，这其中也有一点
element of truth in it and that the masons the illuminati and people like that were kind of progressive that they were the kind of high-minded secularists of their day. And some of them did play roles in these events. And then the whole apparatus of kind of conspiracy theories cranked up around, particularly the Masons, why the Freemasonry was banned, for example, in Franco's Spain, because they were seen as plotting against the Catholic Church and the established order and all the rest of it. And even now, of course, you know, anti-Masonic conspiracy theories are incredibly popular, aren't they? Yes. And I think I mean, the French Revolution is such a kind of explosion.
真相的成分，即共济会、光明会和类似的人群在某种程度上是进步的，他们是那个时代思想高尚的世俗主义者。其中一些人确实在这些事件中发挥了作用。然后，围绕着尤其是共济会的各种阴谋论机制便开动了，例如为什么共济会在佛朗哥的西班牙被禁，因为他们被视为密谋反对天主教教会和既定秩序等等。即使在现在，当然，反共济会的阴谋论也极其受欢迎，不是吗？是的。而且我认为——法国大革命就是这样一场大爆发。
It's such a kind of a shock to the system, I guess, particularly in England, where you've got all the the aristocrats fleeing there i just before christmas i read um tale of two cities for the first time since school yeah what what was really interesting about that was that dickens explains the coming of the french revolution as a kind of conspiracy so he he casts um people in the slums of paris as preparing uh the french revolution and it's like they know exactly what is going to happen. And so obviously, Dickens is kind of projecting his own knowledge of what's going to happen onto these supposed conspirators. But it kind of answers a need that when an event happens that is so unexpected, so seemingly extraordinary, in a way, the idea that there are a bunch of conspirators, be it in a French wine shop in Paris or in a salon in Vienna or whatever, it cuts through a lot of
这可以说是对体制的一种震撼，我想，尤其是在英格兰，那里有所有的贵族在逃亡。就在圣诞节前，我自上学以来第一次读了《双城记》。是的，关于那本书，真正有趣的是狄更斯将法国大革命的到来解释为一种阴谋，所以他把巴黎贫民窟的人们刻画为在筹备法国大革命，就好像他们确切地知道将要发生什么一样。因此，显然狄更斯将自己对将要发生的事情的了解投射到了这些所谓的阴谋者身上。但这在某种程度上满足了一种需求：当发生了一件如此出乎意料、看起来如此非同寻常的事件时，在某种程度上，存在着一帮阴谋者的想法——无论是在巴黎的一家法国葡萄酒店里，还是在维也纳的沙龙里，诸如此类——这省去了很多
the need to explain it. People write entire books about what caused the French Revolution. But if you can say, well, it was all organised by the Illuminati, that makes it a lot simpler, much easier to get a handle on. And you know, another great example of that, Tom, if you ever read any of those books published in the 1920s by people like Agatha Christie, or the Bulldog Drummond books, there's often scenes in them where there's a group of people who are meeting in a shadowy room somewhere. And they're a kind of Jewish financier, an American businessman, a communist, and somebody else. And they talk about how they brought about the First World War, the Russian Revolution, all these cataclysms.
解释它的需要。人们写了整本书来探讨法国大革命的起因。但如果你能说，好吧，这一切都是由光明会组织的话，这就简单多了，更容易掌控了。你知道的，另一个很好的例子，汤姆，如果你读过任何阿加莎·克里斯蒂或《斗牛犬德拉蒙德》系列在1920年代出版的书籍，里面经常会有这样的场景：一群人在某个昏暗的房间里开会。他们是一群犹太金融家、美国商人、共产主义者和另一个人。他们谈论着他们是如何引发第一次世界大战、俄国革命以及所有这些大灾难的。
And it's exactly the same thing that you get with the French Revolution, this search for the network that will explain this seismic, you know, geopolitical convulsion. I don't know if you remember the opening to the film Naked Gun. Fidel Castro and the Ayatollah, and they're all kind of gathered around a table, convulsion i don't know if you remember the opening to the film naked gum fidel castro and the ayatollah and they're all kind of gathered around a table clearly plotting the overthrow of american civilization and leslie nelson but this is the sort of spectral organization james bond isn't it that's what the james bond they have representatives in every country yeah yeah yeah
这与你在法国大革命中看到的完全一样，这种对能够解释这场震撼人心的地缘政治大动荡的网络的不懈探寻。我不知道你是否还记得电影《白头神探》的开场。菲德尔·卡斯特罗和阿亚图拉，他们都围坐在一张桌子旁，大动荡，我不知道你是否还记得电影《白头神探》的开场，菲德尔·卡斯特罗和阿亚图拉，他们都围坐在一张桌子旁，显然在密谋推翻美国文明，而莱斯利·尼尔森……但这就是那种虚幻的组织，詹姆斯·邦德，对吧？这就是詹姆斯·邦德那种……他们在每个国家都有代表，对吧？对吧？
okay right um here's one from thoughtfullyfully Catholic, who is indeed a very thoughtful Catholic. And he has a clearly mad theory. There's a theory that the Vatican conspired to create Islam through the medium of Cardiger, the Catholic first wife of the founder of Islam, all of which is clearly rubbish. That's not true, surely? No, that's of course not true.
好吧，对了，这里有一条来自“思维缜密的天主教徒”（Thoughtfully Catholic）的推文，他确实是一个非常深思熟虑的天主教徒。他有一个显然很疯狂的理论。有一种理论认为，梵蒂冈通过卡迪贾（Cardiger，伊斯兰教创始人伊斯兰教先知穆罕默德的信奉天主教的第一任妻子）这一媒介密谋创立了伊斯兰教，所有这些显然都是无稽之谈。这不是真的吧？不，这当然不是真的。
Of course it's not remotely true um although um i don't want to get us into too much trouble here but the um the beginnings of of islam um i was just about to say yeah there was a conspiracy theory about that right well it's not really a conspiracy it's an academic theory where does it come from um can we trust the um the the muslim sources for it um maybe the muslim sources are themselves in a way um a kind of um if not a conspiracy theory an attempt to explain something that happened in a way that makes sense for people by the time they're writing about it but i won't go into that because i've written an entire book on that and it has the scope to generate all kinds of um of blowback so let's uh leave that one let's part that one let's do a let's move on to yeah yeah so don't worry about the next one
这当然一点也不是真的，不过——虽然我不想在这里惹上太多麻烦——但是关于伊斯兰教的起源，我正要说，是的，确实有一个关于此的阴谋论。好吧，这其实不是一个阴谋，而是一个学术理论。它从何而来？我们能相信关于它的那些穆斯林资料吗？也许穆斯林资料本身在某种程度上也是一种——如果不是阴谋论的话——试图以一种对当时书写它的人来说说得通的方式来解释所发生事情的尝试，但我不会深入探讨这一点，因为我已经就此写了一整本书，而它可能会引发各种各样的反弹，所以让我们把那个搁置一边，把那个暂且不谈，让我们继续……是的，所以不用担心下一个。
so pat roberts has basically pointed us to the theory um which i hadn't heard before the theory that finland doesn't exist that finland is a myth. Apologies to our Finnish listeners, but you are part of the, you're obviously actors playing the part of, yeah, playing a part of Finns. That Finland doesn't exist, that the space where Finland purports to be is actually a giant fishing ground. Is that right, Tom, a giant fishing ground for the Norwegians? Yes, for Japanese, for Japanese fishermen. I think it's a Russian-Japanese conspiracy.
所以帕特·罗伯茨（Pat Roberts）基本上向我们指出了这样一个理论——我以前没听说过这个理论——即芬兰不存在，芬兰是一个神话。向我们的芬兰听众道歉，但你们是其中一部分，你们显然是扮演芬兰人的演员。芬兰不存在，芬兰自称存在的地方实际上是一个巨大的渔场。是这样吗，汤姆，一个属于挪威人的巨大渔场？是的，属于日本人的，属于日本渔民的。我认为这是一个俄国-日本的阴谋。
And this originated kind of three years ago, four years ago. And it's kind of taken off in the darker regions of the internet. And I guess it's kind of fun. I mean, actually, it would be quite fun to just come up with a really insane conspiracy theory and see how long it takes to get traction and i guess again that's the plot of fuko's pendulum um yeah okay would you know he was essentially writing before the internet and and obviously the internet is completely turbocharged but it's also the plot of um our man in havana so yes in in graham green's novel the agent basically invents it to justify his fee same as the tailor of panama but john lecaris take on it later on the agent basically
这起源于大约三四年前。它在互联网的黑暗角落里开始流行。我想这挺有意思的。事实上，编造一个真正疯狂的阴谋论，看看它需要多长时间才能获得关注，其实会挺有意思的。我想这又是《傅科摆》的剧情，对吧？你知道的，他写作时基本上还在互联网之前，显然互联网彻底把这个催化了，但这也是《我们的哈瓦那代理人》的剧情，所以在格雷厄姆·格林的书中，特工基本上是为了证明他的薪水是合理的而编造了它，就像《巴拿马裁缝》里约翰·勒卡雷后来的手法一样，特工基本上
invents a conspiracy where none exists which then comes true yeah so it's albigensian crusade territory yeah but i mean i think the thing about the about the Finland one is that it was clearly, I mean, I imagine it must have been invented as a farm, as a joke. And as these jokes tend to, it seems to have slightly run out of control. It's got legs. Yeah. Anyway, well, now we come to a tweet that just has so many conspiracy theories in it. And tellingly, it's from someone called Nemo. Wow, that's sinister.
凭空捏造了一个并不存在的阴谋，然后这个阴谋变成了现实。是的，所以这是阿尔比十字军东征的领地，对吧？不过，我认为关于芬兰那个理论的关键在于，它显然——我想它一定是被当作一个笑话、一个玩笑发明的。正如这些笑话往往会发展的那样，它似乎有点失控了。它开始流传开来了。是的。无论如何，现在我们看到了一条包含如此多阴谋论的推文。说明问题的是，它来自一个叫内莫（Nemo）的人。哇，这太阴险了。
So who knows who this could be? I mean, it might be Prince Philip. It might be the CIA. Who knows who it might be? Anyway, he's the faked moon landing. Prince Philip killed Diana. The US government assassinated John Lennon. The CIA killed Bob Marley.
所以谁知道这可能是谁呢？我的意思是，这可能是菲利普亲王。这可能是中情局。谁知道这可能是谁呢？总之，他列举了：伪造登月，菲利普亲王谋杀戴安娜，美国政府暗杀约翰·列侬，中情局谋杀鲍勃·马利。
Well, we've... Which of these is the maddest? Why would the CIA kill Bob Marley don't know I'm not familiar with that one why would the Reagan government assassinate John Lennon again it's not the Reagan government it's Jimmy Carter
好吧，我们有……这些里面哪一个是最疯狂的？中情局为什么要谋杀鲍勃·马利？不知道，我对这个不太熟悉。里根政府为什么要暗杀约翰·列侬？再说一次，这不是里根政府，这是吉米·卡特。
it's the Jimmy Carter Jimmy Carter Mr Human Rights can you see him signing that off is there not a link between Mark David Chapman killing John Lennon and whoever it was that then shot reagan hinkley john hinkley that hinkley was inspired by chapman shooting uh i don't know whether he was inspired by mark chapman he was definitely inspired by the film
这是吉米·卡特，吉米·卡特，人权先生，你能想象他签署这个命令吗？马克·大卫·查普曼刺杀约翰·列侬，和后来枪击里根的那个人——欣克利，约翰·欣克利——之间难道没有联系吗？即欣克利是受了查普曼枪击的启发……我不知道他是否受了马克·查普曼的启发，他绝对是受了电影
taxi driver um yeah in which which has the um uh robert, Travis Bickle character. I think he was because it was only a few, it was kind of a couple of months, two or three months after John Lennon was shot. What is certainly true is that there is a personality type. There are people who feel victimised and they're outsiders and all the rest of it. And it's often the case that people who've assassinated American political figures will have had scrapbooks or something of previous assassins and they want to be as famous as Lee Harvey Oswald
《出租车司机》的启发，嗯，电影里有罗伯特·德尼罗饰演的特拉维斯·比克尔（Travis Bickle）这个角色。我想他是受了启发，因为那只过了几个月，在约翰·列侬被枪击的两三个月后。可以肯定的是，确实存在一种人格类型。有些人感到自己被边缘化了，他们是局外人，诸如此类。通常情况下，刺杀美国政治人物的人会收集前刺客的剪贴簿之类的信息，他们想变得和李·哈维·奥斯瓦尔德一样出名，
or the guy who shot George Wallace or the guy who shot Robert Kennedy or, you know, that this is a sort of pattern that they then want to live up to themselves. I mean, there are two, there's a much better Beatles conspiracy, of course, which is Paul McCartney never died. Paul McCartney died in 1966.
或是枪击乔治·华莱士的人，或是枪击罗伯特·肯尼迪的人，或者诸如此类，这是一种他们随后想要效仿的模式。我的意思是，有两个，当然还有一个更好的披头士阴谋，那就是保罗·麦卡特尼从未死过。保罗·麦卡特尼死于1966年。
Yeah, Paul McCartney died in 1966, got replaced, and this replacement of many things was able to write H.E.D. Yeah. Let it be. I know that that conspiracy is not true because Paul McCartney once saw me
是的，保罗·麦卡特尼死于1966年，然后被替换了，而这个替代者在很多事情上都能够写出……是的。《Let It Be》。我知道这个阴谋不是真的，因为保罗·麦卡特尼曾经看到我
shouting at my son when he was small for throwing gravel. This was my counter. This was my real brush for greatness. Yeah, of course. Yeah, you'd say that, Dominic. Of course you'd say that. I do that thing that you should never do as a parent, which is basically really lose it in public
对我的儿子大喊大叫，当时他很小，因为他在扔石子。这是我的反证。这是我真正与伟大人物擦肩而过的经历。是的，当然。是的，你当然会这么说，多米尼克。你当然会这么说。我做了那种作为父母绝不应该做的事情，那就是基本上在公共场合彻底失控，
over what appears to be the smallest thing, but is actually unknown to the rest of everybody who's watching the thousandth in a series of incidents i've told you a thousand times about throwing gravel stop throwing gravel and i looked up and there was paul mccartney who gave me this sort of this sort of avuncular wink and then moved on you didn't do a thumbs up no but i thought you know this isn't how it was meant to go my my meeting with Paul McCartney. Come on. But the other one that kind of – every time there is a mention, every time some famous star gets killed or dies – so Elvis is the classic, but it's been said of John Lennon as well.
为了看似最小的事情，但实际上在其他所有围观的人看来，这是我无数次警告中的第一千次——我跟你说过一千遍了不要扔石子，别再扔石子了——我抬起头，看到保罗·麦卡特尼给了我这种——这种长辈般的眨眼，然后走开了。你没有竖大拇指吗？没有，但我当时想，我和保罗·麦卡特尼的相遇不应该是这样的。拜托。但另一个——每当有提及，每当某个著名的明星被谋杀或去世时——埃尔维斯是个经典的例子，但约翰·列侬也有这种说法。
It's been said of Bob Marley. It's been said of Jim Morrison. I guess it's been said of Marilyn as well. Did they really die? Are they – Yeah. Are they all somewhere? So is that because they're kind of saints to their followers
人们对鲍勃·马利这么说过。人们对吉姆·莫里森这么说过。我想人们对玛丽莲·梦露也这么说过。他们真的死了吗？他们是——是的。他们都在某个地方吗？所以这是因为他们对追随者来说就像圣人一样，
and their followers can't believe that they could ever die? I mean, what's all that about? Something like that. I don't know. I don't know. But it's a kind of interesting meme. And there's also this weird thing, isn't there, that the US government is always the perpetrator,
而他们的追随者无法相信他们会死？我的意思是，这到底是怎么回事？差不多是这样。我不知道。我不知道。但这是一种有趣的模因。还有一个奇怪的现象，对吧，那就是美国政府总是罪魁祸首，
that the US government is staffed by people who hate rock and roll and even now you know 50 or 60 years on have never come to terms with bill haley in the comments and are determined to wipe out a succession of big stars yeah i mean the elvis one i guess isn't i guess because elvis becomes uh he gets a badge from Nixon, doesn't he? He is. Great pals with Nixon. So maybe the sense that Elvis vanishes because actually he's working for the American government, but clearly with John Lennon, because the American government wanted to deport him. Yeah. I'm sure that's what feeds into that.
美国政府里塞满了讨厌摇滚乐的人，甚至现在——在五六十年后——仍然无法接受比尔·哈利和彗星乐队（Bill Haley & His Comets），并决心消灭一连串的大明星。是的，我的意思是关于埃尔维斯的那个，我想是因为埃尔维斯成为了——他从尼克松那里得到了一枚徽章，对吧？他是尼克松的铁哥们。所以也许有一种感觉，埃尔维斯消失是因为实际上他在为美国政府工作，但显然对于约翰·列侬来说，是因为美国政府想把他驱逐出境。是的。我确信这就是滋生这种说法的温床。
The idea that the people in the CIA had a kind of desire to get rid of him. And essentially that's what then feeds into the X-Files. Yeah, well, the X-Files obviously builds on all this sort of stuff. All that kind of stuff, and it also has aliens and things. So I reckon of those, I reckon the most plausible, Prince Philip killed Diana. I don't think Prince Philip... I can't believe you said that.
中情局的人有一种想要除掉他的愿望的想法。这基本上就是后来滋生《X档案》的原因。是的，好吧，《X档案》显然建立在所有这些基础之上。所有类似的东西，里面还有外星人和诸如此类的事物。所以我觉得在这些里面，我觉得最貌似有理的是：菲利普亲王谋杀戴安娜。我不认为菲利普亲王……我不敢相信你这么说了。
Of all of those, of all of those... Tom destroys his credibility. Tom believes that Prince Philip killed Diana. You've heard it here first. Just for destroys his credibility. Tom believes that Prince Philip killed Diana. You've heard it here first. Just for the record, I don't think Prince Philip killed Diana. But of all of those, I think the Diana death is kind of the one that perhaps... I'd be interested to see how they play that on The Crown. Oh, God almighty, don't go there.
在所有这些里面，在所有这些里面……汤姆毁了自己的信誉。汤姆相信菲利普亲王谋杀了戴安娜。你在这里第一次听到这个。仅做记录，我不认为菲利普亲王谋杀了戴安娜。但在所有这些里面，我认为戴安娜的死可能是那种……我很想看看他们在《王冠》中是如何演绎这一段的。哦，上帝万能，别提那个了。
But you, Dominic, as an expert, I'll look forward to your thoughts on that. And as such a huge fan of The Crown, as is well known. Anyway, that is all we've got time for today. Dominic and I are both due in Moscow this afternoon. If you've enjoyed today's podcast, please do rate and review us, although obviously only if you like it. Until next time, bye. Watch out for the lizards.
但你，多米尼克，作为一个专家，我将拭目以待你对此的想法。而且作为一个众所周知的《王冠》超级粉丝。无论如何，我们今天的时间就到这里。我和多米尼克今天下午都要去莫斯科。如果你喜欢今天的播客，请给我们评分和评论，当然，前提是你真的喜欢它。下次见，拜拜。当心蜥蜴人。
Goodbye. access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。访问无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。